In fact, the insurance industry is rolling out the big guns...
...and breaking out their massive war chest...
...to marshal their forces for one last fight to save the status quo.
They're filling the airwaves with deceptive and dishonest ads.
They're flooding Capitol Hill with lobbyists and campaign contributions.
And they're funding studies designed to mislead the American people.
Of course, like clockwork, we've seen folks on cable television who know better,...
...waving these industry-funded studies in the air.
We've seen industry insiders and their apologists...
...citing these studies as proof of claims that just aren't true.
They'll claim that premiums will go up under reform.
But they know that the nonpartisan Congressional Budget Office...
...found that reforms will lower premiums in a new insurance exchange,...
...while offering consumers protections that will limit out-of-pocket costs...
...and prevent discrimination based on pre-existing conditions.
They'll claim that you'll have to pay more out-of-pocket.
But they know that this is based on a study that willfully ignores whole sections of the bill...
...including tax credits and cost savings that will greatly benefit middle class families.
Even the authors of one of these studies have now admitted publicly...
...that the insurance companies actually asked them to do an incomplete job.
It's smoke and mirrors.
It's bogus and it's all too familiar.
Every time we get close to passing reform,...
...the insurance companies produce these phony studies as a prescription and say,...
..."Take one of these and call us in a decade."
Well, not this time.